ah
damn it slip chain
i hate these small limbs like that it
happens with chainsaws
i gotta fix this up the fun ain't over
yet
okay i got my poles time to get to work
what i want to do is get this bark off
then i'm gonna make a point
and drive it in the ground one of the
benefits of living in the woods you
gotta be creative
if you're not creative you're gonna
struggle
try to use a little bit of caveman
knowledge to make things a little more
comfortable
i'm able to survive out here but i want
to thrive out here too
okay bench is done
you guys want to check it out have some
hot chalk yeah
that's cooler than i expected it's
awesome huh
yeah we got our rocks
we got our cottonwood we got our bench
nice backrest
you see how this thing is look so just
smolders
before western society came before there
was matches and lighters and stuff
this is how back in the day people
carried their spark
because believe me no matter how good
you are at making a fire
you wouldn't be able to make one at 50
below and without this spark without
this birch punk right here
easily we could not be here today we'd
be wiped out extinct in this area of the
earth
whatever created us and created the
earth made it possible with tools like
this
growing right on the trees so that's
good to think about you know
i know it was my favorite part of the
day what this
this is your favorite part good one
now that these nets are gone we got the
perfect spot
you